i was also introduced at that time
to the idea jessica in judo i think in
jiu-jitsu is the same
a lot of sports is probably the same is
there's ways to win that include
kind of um if i were to use a bad term
stalling which is like use strategy to
slow down
to destroy all the weapons your opponent
has and just to wait it out
to sort of break your opponent by
yeah shutting down all their weapons but
not using any of your own
yes and now travis was always going for
he's of of course really good at
gripping and con to that whole game but
he was going for the big throws
and he was almost getting frustrated uh
by
a lot of the opponents i remember uh
uh ola bischoff i think yes uh
from germany from germany very talented
very incredible i know he's very good at
doing big throws and he's incredible
judoka but he was also incredible
at just frustrating his opponents with
like gripping and strategy and so on
and i just remember feeling the pain of
this person
like travis who went through just he
broke like every part of his body
he went through so many injuries just
this person who dedicated his entire
life
to this moment in 2008 and then 2012
and 2016 just ever gave everything you
could see it on his face
uh that you know it's
his weapons are being shut down and he's
still pushing forward he's still with
that both the frustration
and the power i mean the the the kind of
throw he does
is the his his main one i think is the
standing
was called sayonagi people saying i can
the apologize he used was the these big
throws
that there's something to me about the
synagogue i fell in love with that throw
that's my become my main throw standing
sanagi
that is like why do why do you favor the
standing variation because of the
amplitude
you get a more powerful yeah power
it's like are you a fan of koga yes
that's so that's why
travis so koga and travis opened up
my uh travis uses the same gripping
patterns for saying ikea's coco
all the same and the way he uses his
hips and turns
and i remember like going to my judo
club and other judo clubs and
ask and they're all saying this is the
wrong way to do it
the way travis does is the wrong way to
do it and i remember like i've always
been amazed by this by the way
i don't mean to cut you off but i i
could literally
fill 20 hours of reproductions of people
who will tell me that
either my students or other great world
champions
um are doing things wrong yeah and
i'm i'm looking at them and i'm like
who would i rather trust here in in
their judgment
koga who was one of the greatest
throwers
of all time or you
[Laughter]
a recreational guy who couldn't throw my
grandmother yes
um uh i'm supposed to take your word
over his well say don't listen to what
people
say i'm gonna give you a piece of advice
here watch what the best people
do okay that's how you get
superior athletic performance i'm gonna
say that again
don't listen to what people say watch
what they do
particularly under the stress of high
level competition because that's when
you see their real game
what they really do under pressure okay
and if you can emulate that
you're going to be very successful i
guess what i was frustrated with
to your point is that the argument
against koga is
what he has a very specific body type
and he figured out something that worked
for him
thus the statement is that might not be
applicable to you or to the general
public
of of uh judo players that want to
succeed
that by the way at the shallow level
might be true might be true the point is
there might be a body of knowledge
that's yet to be discovered and explored
that koga opened up that i wanted to
understand
why his technique worked
it made no sense to me that with a
single foot like the way you turn the
hip
the single foot that steps in why does
that work
because it was actually very difficult
to make work
for me as a white belt in the very
beginning it doesn't make
sense like people just they don't they
don't get loaded up onto your hip
anyway for people don't watch koga
highlights watch travis stevens
highlights
but the the the details of the technique
don't make sense
but one mastered that it feels like
there's something fundamental there that
hasn't been explored yet
it's like koga and travis made me think
that we don't know most
of the body mechanics involved in
dominance in judo
like we just kind of found a few pockets
that work really well the ichimoda
there's these different throws
also i wonder if there's like totally
cool new things that we haven't
discovered and that's saying i
gave a little peek because there's very
few people that i'm aware of that do it
the way travis and koga did
may i ask you a question yes um
the choice of standing sanagi um i i
should
uh say this for you for your listeners
they're probably thinking what the hell
are these two guys talking about
um uh sanagi is one of the more high
percentage throws in the olympic sport
of judah
um probably uh
ucha mata is probably number one and
variations of sanagi would be
in the top five for sure um the basic
choice you have
in modern competition is the more
difficult standing sanagi
where you literally are up on your feet
and you perform
a shoulder throw that takes your
opponent over from a full
standing position the most popular form
of synagi and modern competition by a
landslide is not the standing version
it's a drop saying argue where you go
down to your knees
this means you have a much easier time
getting underneath your opponent's
center of gravity the defining feature
of any synagogue
is getting underneath your opponent's
center of gravity and lifting them that
ceo
literally means to to lift and carry
why did you choose the more difficult
version what was your motivation
you know you're a smart kid you know
right from the start
that for every standing sanagi there's
20 drops and argues in modern
competition one is obviously more high
percentage
one obviously works for a wider variety
of body types
uh the number of people who are
successful with standing synagogue is
dramatically lower
and it appears to be a move which is
completely absent in the heavyweight
divisions
and rarely seen in the lightweight
divisions
why what was the motivation why did you
willingly adopt the less
high percentage over the this would be
very interesting percentage i i
i i would love you to break it apart
because um
i apply the same kind of thinking to
basically everything i mentioned to you
offline there's these
boston dynamics spot robots when i first
met spot i found love
i don't understand what exactly but
there's magic there and i just got
excited by it
and that mat that fire burns i want to
work these robots i want to work with
robots
i want to i felt like there was
something special there that
i could build something interesting with
create something interesting with
and the same with with the synagogue
standing synagi
from koga and travis i just fell in love
with that technique just even watching i
didn't even know what the hell to do
with it
was it aesthetic it's the standing scene
i guess more beautiful in execution
there's no
engine in my own
let's we're talking about love here
right in my own
definition of aesthetic yes it's not
just beauty because you could argue
there's more elegance sort of uchamata
is very beautiful and effortless
i love i love something about the
dominance of it
i love the idea in sport
of two people that are the best in the
world
and one of them dominating the other
and uh to me the standing say nagi
you're lifted off your feet
and especially when it's done perfectly
and with really strong resistance from
the other person
it results in a big slam and that was
like beautiful to me
that's the uh alexander carell and like
big pickups
i love that it's interesting
you're correct and so far as you you're
not just going with aesthetic and the
sense of beauty but also
but you are making uh as it were value
judgments yes about the throw
and that's fascinating to me um
because there's two elements
to any grappling sport i've always i'm
always
um insistent upon the idea that
jiu-jitsu is both
an art and a science okay it has
scientific elements insofar as it
works according to the laws of physics
and lever and fulcrum etc etc
um but it also has
an aesthetic element and so far as
you're making choices
with technique you're expressing who you
are as a person you have
10 000 different variations of moves you
could use but you're specifically
choosing these
that's an element of choice and
self-expression on your part and insofar
as that is true
combat sports and not just a size but
they're also an art
so most combat sports have this sense
which they
have the features of both an art and a
science and
it's not just about high percentage
in in your case i mean me personally i'm
obsessed with
percentages what what are the ways to
make signs yeah
but that's also choices involved yeah
but um uh but there is an
undeniably aesthetic element
to martial arts where you as it were
express
who you are as a person in terms of the
techniques you're ultimately going to
choose
does that get in the way do you allow
yourself to enjoy the aesthetic beauty
of a technique
of course yeah when i when martial arts
have done well
it's the most beautiful sport in the
world okay when it's done poorly it's
the ugliest
but um but
a beautifully applied submission holder
perfect throw
a superbly set up takedown
are among the most difficult techniques
to execute in all of sports and when
they're done well they're magic to
observe
but do you uh prefer certain techniques
over others because of their
like for example i'll tell you for me
chokes
of all sorts with the ghee without the
ghee probably with the geese the most
beautiful to me personally
i i value them above all others
people mostly associate myself and my
students with leg locking
they're usually rather surprised to
learn that i actually value
strangleholds far above leg logs
but not for aesthetic reasons for
effectiveness we can talk about that
later if you wish
you